khalifé novelli c'est quoi votre moule
est alors c'était le 14 février derniers
mois pour la saint valentin
ouais si ch'est fleuriste là à boulogne
à côté ouais chercher un prix de flore
pour matthieu delormeau way et j'ai mis
ma voiture en warning wef juste devant
le fleuriste pour aller vite je me suis
dit que ça allait aller vite et en fait
ça a mis plus de temps que prévu parce
que tous les maris étaient en train
d'acheter des fleurs à leur femme et
donc du coup j'entends une dame une
personne âgée qui crie dehors qu'est
qu'ils étaient dans le quartier oui mais
moi en mode curieuse je mets ma tête est
en fait serment qu'elle s'adressait nom
et elle m'a dit vous vous prenez pour
qui avec votre voiture en warning
je vais vous crevez votre petite conne
non pas mal vous connaissez ces retours
neigeux et d'imagés vous crevez autre
chose vieille conne no 10 non mais là je
me suis dit bon j'ai pas le temps plus
tard tard pour venir ici donc je suis
parti mais morale à cette histoire c'est
quoi bah c'est pas parce que nous sommes
des personnes âgées
je m'adresse à toutes les vieilles dames
et à tous les vieux ma gauche à gauche
vous n'avez pas l'immunité vous n'avez
pas le totem vous ne pouvez pas vous
permettre de parler mal aux gens si vous
êtes vieux qu'on va pas vous tapez
[Applaudissements]
mais ça tombait bien halal est sorti et
le reste c'est pas parce que les
personnes âgées nous respecte
d'assurance à l'usagé oui bien entendu
et on ne tape pas les personnages etc et
gilles on est d'accord
alors là jamais jamais jamais mais n'est
pas des excuses à faire toutes les
personnes de jouer pas 10 ou sur moi et
ça aurait fait l'effet que cette
chaussure isabelle sèmerait la zizanie
sur moi bâle roche c'est une partie de
moi généré je n'irai jamais tapé une
personne âgée le message n'a pas compris
c'est qu'à la fin tu as dit taper les
personnes âgées alors que tu voulais
durer ce nom parce que la dame a menacé
oui parce que vous êtes des personnes
âgées et vous permet à vous n'êtes pas
immunisés enfin on a quand même pas les
gens comme ça gratuit mais il faut pas
taper les personnes ayant bien voilà
sauf si elle le mérite non mais non
[Applaudissements]
là